so I want you to think about you're an
animal and you live in the jungle I know
this sounds crazy and all the sounds you
hear all this stuff but you are so naive
about how all the other animals in the
jungle are wired and you're trying to
survive how long do you think you would
last in that jungle as any animal how
long do you think it would survive one
day 6 hours 12 hours how long not a long
time all it takes is one evening and you
go out to try to do something you're
someone's prey and you're dead that's
exactly how it is in a world of business
if you don't study other personalities
and how they're wires and if you don't
study how this you know a kingdom of
entrepreneurship this is not animal
kingdom I can call it the entrepreneur
Kingdom is infested with all these
different personalities you ain't going
to last a long time in business last
night I was having a conversation about
five-year-old son Tico also Patrick
Gabriel bird David and I always asked
him the question daddy what are the four
most important things that we focus on
as a family love respect improve and a
real lead right and then I say hey do we
bully know do you do we get bullied no
then asking the question daddy who loves
you says daddy you love me and the last
time he tells me says daddy everyone
loves me and I said daddy I wish
everybody loved me and I wish everybody
loved you sometimes okay we we paint
this picture of life as so perfect that
our kids get surprised and sometimes we
paint this picture of business so
friendly and nice and you're going to
become so successful and everybody wants
you to win big and then you face someone
that's not like that then you're eaten
alive and you're saying wait a minute
this sucks
everyone's horrible no it's just how
people are wired and by the way I'll
cover 15 different animals and what
their personalities are and how they're
wired and how they do things and how
they decide and you can look at them as
personality to keep it going to do
business with you can't just say I am
only going to do with people that are
just like me nope and you get to do
business with only a couple people
because you got to learn how to do
business with all these different
personalities and some of them are going
to rub you the wrong way let's get right
into it number one is an eagle an eagle
fly solo thereby
himself their strengths they're strong
they're independent they know how to
feed themselves they don't need your
help to feed them but they're not a
leader of another group they're so low
they're independent I don't how to make
money I'm good I don't need your help
that's how they are they they are
generally going to be ok for themselves
but if you decide to do business with
somebody like that just keep in mind
they're about themselves you got a
position I'm in the right place for you
get to the best out of them next is a
horse horse very simple hard-working
they're very about they're much about
servanthood they want to serve people
they're hardworking they make incredible
people running operations they made
incredible people in an environment to
make sure things get to work things you
know at time somebody needs to do the
dirty work it could take 20 hours of
every day over three weeks span they
don't have a problem doing it just make
sure you treat them right because when
they kick it hurts a lot because then
when they kick you're going to feel it
when you get a kick on these horses like
the one you just saw right here it hurts
a lot when that takes place number 3
shark and wolf very similar let me
explain to you about like like this guy
who just came out are our little friend
you think you were like starring in Jaws
like who do you think you are huh go
back home Brooke I'm doing a video here
see how scary these guys look let me
tell you something about these guys huge
sharks and wolves when you do business
with them kind sharks care about one
thing and that's money profit making
money that's all it is this is what
their mindset is that ok they're willing
to make money generally at all cost when
I say at all cost they will go to the
line if the line is here breaking the
laws they're right here is where they
are sharks because it's all about money
now sometimes wolves are dressed like
sheeps and if you don't know about it
they will eat you up alive now someone
says well should I never do business
with sharks and they're wolves no it's
ok if you do business with them as long
as your attorneys write the contract not
the other way around if their rap they
write up the contract I'm not doing
business with them I had a couple guys I
want the business with me and do certain
things I said nope you have 66 percent
I'm 34 I'm not interested because I'm
not the one here that all of the sounds
going to make a decision I don't have an
I don't have any interest in doing that
part because they're coming from here
now if I'm betting that they're going to
make money they
we'll make money you just need to know
this personality next rhino rhinos are
the ones that will work their tails off
and put their head down and get to work
just sometimes on their way to wherever
they're going their destination is they
break a lot of things so they're not the
most they're not the most what's the
word I'm looking for Paul finesse they
don't have finesse there is not about
finesse it's just I'm gonna you want me
to get over there I'm gonna get to that
destination I'm gonna run through some
trees I may run through a couple people
I may have step down a couple animals
here Bob we'll get to that place here so
you need to know where to position a
Rhino when you're in business with them
don't expect them to have a lot of
finesse next sheep unfortunately sheep
in the world of politics politicians get
elected because they master how to
communicate with them see they're not
trying to get the votes of somebody who
understands the games of politics this
is how they get elected and you need to
understand as you're watching this this
is the last thing you want to be
most people they say I am NOT a sheep
there's no way I'm a sheep everyone is a
sheep in something let me explain if
you've never played the money game
investments finance real estate you've
never bought a home you know nothing
about investment you're a sheep in that
world and if you're not careful about
educating yourself about money someone's
going to take advantage if you run into
the wrong person so everyone is the
sheep in something you just got to make
sure you get educating the business that
you're in doing business with and you
definitely don't wanna be sheep long
term in the world of business because
somebody will devour you learn how to
become a better business person monkey
let me tell you monkeys here's what one
good thing and a bad thing about monkeys
in the world of business they are so
attractive and so entertaining because
all they want to do is have fun there's
so much about monkeying around and
having fun and telling jokes and all
this other stuff that they can actually
convert you into their show that they're
putting up and you don't get any
business done that's what they do
monkeys they procrastinate a lot they're
more worried about hey let's grab a beer
afterwards let's go have fun afterwards
let's go to a club that's what monkeys
are doing in the business I did a lot of
business with people who had this
personality that was a priority I have
to know the difference and separate
myself to be focused on a business that
was growing next a flop unfortunately
you're going to recruit them
a lot of people who are slots it's going
to happen lazy nothing gets done it's
just very slope they give you a deadline
of this you know 13th they're not going
to get it into the 30th if you tell them
to get something done by one o'clock
tomorrow four o'clock in the afternoon
maybe and if you say I'm so sick and
tired of doing business with a slob Ida
fired them or you adjust to them because
they're not changing that's how they are
wired or slots if you have them in your
environment many many many of them stay
like this appeal them change next a lion
lion is a controversial one because a
lot of people love to say I'm a lion
heart I'm a lion I'm a dis I'm of that
so many people think their lines but you
eventually takes 5 10 15 20 years
sometimes to figure out who the real
lion in an environment was there are a
lot of wannabe lions there's a lot of
people that are loud and make a lot of
noise like lines but lions is here lion
is not here lion is how you perform
during difficult challenges all that
other stuff the one that talks a lot is
a great promoter but a line is the one
that's going to get the job and everyone
respects them that this is the leader
listen one of my favorite quotes of all
time said by philosopher is if lions
could talk we could not understand them
here's why Lions are visionaries they
see the future they see what it is to
run the jungle they see who is harmless
they see who can harm that he was
playing games the lion looks at the
whole picture of the jungle okay they
don't just look at one part of it they
see what's going on and they're good at
you know becoming the kings in the world
of business you as you're watching this
if you either a line that's great now
the next goal is to make sure you also
know how to breathe other lines to take
over jungles and their own business if
you're in the business of building
leaders next we have snakes you're going
to face a lot of snakes on business
they're everywhere you can't run away
from them they're going to be in
business they're in politics they're in
families they're in relationships
they're in your apartment building
you're living in you have neighbors in
your community you have people on TV you
have people out of your friends you
don't even know but they have snake
tendencies and they're always
maneuvering they're always maneuvering
they always have to have something on
you they're always you got to be careful
with them and by the way
for some that Seattle never do business
with a person as a snake if you're doing
business with a massive amount of people
there could be a couple people on there
you just got to keep your eye ready for
them because you're probably doing
business with them but you don't know
about the next cap caps are very they're
very strategic calculating you know
because there's so much in the survival
mode you know the how nine lives that
hey let me see what I can do to get this
from here and let me act like I'm not
interested and I'm not hurt or I don't
care but I really do and I don't want to
act like I care about any of this stuff
but I'm gonna get what I want because I
know how to play this games in it
that's cats and by the way it's
attractive but you also got to know
who's the cat and the sooner you know
who's the cat so you know how to adjust
to the cat tendencies on how they are
dogs phenomenal easy loyal great
listeners you know they're they're great
as a partner they're great as a board
that wants to take feedback and they're
not they're very fair and they're able
to give you feedback on everything
they're not afraid to tell you the truth
but they're willing to listen to you
encouraging the great great partners and
people to be in business with dolphins
every company needs a dolphin dolphins
are extremely smart and they're
incredible communicators right that's
what they're known for
those are great combinations for people
in business smart in communication are
you kidding me this is like a beautiful
partnership to have in there non-stop so
workers that are thinking smart and
communication you're in a good place
you're Fox non-commital they don't ever
fully commit they're always afraid they
always think someone's after them they
always think someone's about to get them
because they're wired like that they
think everybody else is wired like that
you gotta ask yourself the question why
are foxes the way they are why are they
so you know paranoid about everybody
because you got a watch they know who
they are
so they think everybody is like them but
the world's not like them that's why
they fall prey to foxes because foxes
are non-committal and they come and get
what they want and all of a sudden so
your prey too late they took on your
people they did one over here they did
one over there you lost a couple P
that's foxes they're very good at what
they do okay chicken chickens are just
afraid they're sensitive smallest thing
you say to them their family you said
this barnyard oh that's a rooster okay
you know chicken I told you chicken in
position doing big it some of your
simple stuff I'm trying to get Paul to
realize a different sound effects of
animals eventually we're gonna figure
this thing out Paul what do you think
yes we'll figure this thing out the okay
so chickens are afraid they're sensitive
you tell them something they back down
if you have somebody that works for you
in your environment they don't know how
to make decisions you're always going to
try to please everybody they just don't
make good leaders
chickens don't and if you're somebody
that's watching is your chicken and if
you want to go out and become somebody
else you may want to start working on
adjusting that because in a world of
business you're going to make it too
long for you know just think about what
meat we eat a lot wheat a lot of chicken
okay so you do not want to be a chicken
you get eaten up pretty quickly and I
last but not least elephants smart
brilliant powerful but they move very
slow okay they're smart they're powerful
they have a lot of strength but they
move very very slow is what elephants
are they going to move at their pace
they're not going to let your pace
they're not going to be the most
successful influential all this other
stuff they're going to do that their
pace but they're actually good at what
they do
so I shared this with you for a very
simple reason I get a lot of people that
say I had this business part and didn't
work out emails I put a million and a
half dollars in this business but it
didn't work out because the guys up with
business business that and you know I
was working over here and this is what I
did in this little works look here's
where you are I told you the difference
animals in the animal kingdom or in the
jungle and you can take this and look at
all the different personalities I'm just
giving you 15 of them that you're going
to do business with if you don't adjust
based on this and it happens to you it's
on you it's not on everybody else you
were given the information it's as if
you're an animal coming to our jungle to
want to live in this jungle and somebody
gave you the instruction on all the
animal what you decide to do from here
moving forward it's on you because you
are the final decision-maker on the
choices that you make
and people who become successful
eventually one of their biggest strength
is they know how to read people
they have intuition to have a feel I
don't feel good about this person
because it's only about them and I have
to be careful not necessarily going to
fire them but I need to be very very
careful because this person changes very
quickly from your friend to an enemy you
need to be careful with this person
you're right they're not forgiving
they're not this this person men there's
such an amazing person I'm trying to get
this person to be this person
but this person's phenomenal at this
position why am i trying to change them
I need to make sure I reposition them in
a better place to get the best out of
them that's on you to do so with that
being said that's the message of the day
for you on value team and take care
everybody bye bye hey thanks for
watching this video let me make a case
to why I believe you need to subscribe
to value team and also join a
notification squad look there's two ways
you can learn about business one of the
ways of go to college learn a bunch of
theories by professors who I probably
never run a business before or you can
watch value tainment ran by
entrepreneurs who have built and sold
businesses and you can learn from our
mistakes and what we did right and by
the way I'm willing to bet anybody who
goes and takes this boring route vs.
watches value tainment I'm putting my
money this person watches item is going
to beat the person who goes to college
you don't believe me test me on this
this is why I'm so certain you need to
subscribe to value tainment and learn
the content so you can also be
successful
you
[Music]